Protests in China against the government's strict COVID measures there have intensified,...
...with some people publicly venting their anger at leaders of the Communist Party.
Thousands of protesters took to the streets of Shanghai,...
...calling for President Xi Jinping to step down.
The BBC saw people being bundled into police cars.
These images are from Beijing, where students gathered at the elite Tsinghua University...
...and hundreds called for democracy,...
...rule of law and freedom of expression.
Students also demonstrated at the University of Nanjing,...
...while the protests began after a deadly fire in the western city of Urumqi.
Some blame COVID controls for a delay in putting that fatal fire out.